épicier arabe c'est ça le projet je me
suis engagé auprès de la banque à leur
terre titre est le gérant
avec cette épicerie je te mets à l'abri
j'ai refusé
c'est un seul chance d'être responsable
de quelque chose qui je refuse je suis
sur un gros coup là une grosse affaire
moi je la connais tu as quoi ça tient
chaque six pour tenir au rmi comme lui
non le championnat du monde à béziers
avec sa famille lors la clé en asie
voilà train cette année vous attendez
encore là mais je non pas de la drogue
non plus maman tu sais la pétanque c'est
ma passion
la pétanque à 10 ans étaient touchants
pendant un temps c'était marrant
aujourd'hui à 40 ans c'est navrant et la
pétanque c'est pas un métier
les secours mais je suis français y est
que toi que c'est bon et c'est pas la
peine on se comprend pas la suisse tu
parles comme temps perd lui aussi dit
bon d'accord il ya longtemps qu'on l'ait
pas entendu je suis là
oui au momo
ce que je vais t'apprendre 10 à 3 ou
geremek enfants ce qu'ils savent allait
rentrer